en esta ocasión tenemos cuatro monedas
en una bolsa de las cuales tres de estas
monedas son monedas de truco y la moneda
restante es una moneda normal
las monedas de truco tienen la trampa de
que lanzarlas al aire la probabilidad de
que salga cruz en estas monedas es del
45% si tú eliges al azar una de estas
monedas y las lanzas al aire cuatro
veces cuál es el porcentaje de
probabilidad de que obtengas cuatro
caras seguidas así que tenemos otro
problema de probabilidad de pendiente
como lo vamos a resolver
bueno pues de la misma manera que el
otro voy a hacer dos ramas para calcular
mi árbol de probabilidades en la primera
rama voy a platicarles acerca de qué es
lo que pasa con las monedas de truco y
si te das cuenta como son cuatro monedas
y tres de ellas son de truco la
probabilidad de sacar una moneda de
truco es de tres cuartos ahora la
probabilidad de sacar una moneda normal
es de un cuarto porque solamente tenemos
una moneda normal de las cuatro que
tenemos y por lo tanto ya tengo mis dos
ramas mi rama de las normales
de las del truco así que primero vamos a
hablar un poco acerca de las del truco
si te das cuenta lo que nos dicen es que
las monedas de truco tienen el 45% de
probabilidad de caer cruz mientras que
el resto es decir lo que le falta de 45%
para llegar al cien por ciento que es a
55 por ciento de caer cara en cada una
de mis monedas de truco tenemos el 45
por ciento de caer cruz y el 55 por
ciento de caer karam qué pasa con las
maneras normales pues bueno son las
monedas que utilizamos siempre es decir
se encuentra por ciento de que caigan
karam y 50 por ciento de que caigan cruz
50 por ciento de cruz y 50 por ciento de
karam y después vamos a lanzar esta
moneda que escogimos cuatro veces al
aire entonces si yo lo que quiero saber
es cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
cuatro caras pues lo que hay que hacer
es multiplicar la probabilidad de
obtener cara por ella misma por cuatro
veces es decir en cada lanzamiento de la
moneda que es un truco tenemos la
probabilidad de 55% de que caiga cara si
lo lanzamos una vez es 0.55 dos veces
0.55 tres veces 0.55 y 4
0.55 y todo esport porque estamos
calculando la probabilidad de que caiga
cara y cara y cara y cara y a todo esto
hay que multiplicarlo por la
probabilidad de que cuando nosotros
metamos la mano a la bolsa saquemos una
moneda de truco es decir al final la
probabilidad de toda esta rama me va a
quedar tres cuartos por 0.55 elevado a
la cuarta potencia porque darse cuenta
que aquí tenemos 0.55 multiplicado por
si mismo cuatro veces y bueno ahorita
sacó la calculadora para hacer todas
estas cuentas entonces ahora me voy a
fijar en la siguiente rama tengo una
probabilidad del 50% de que caiga cara
por lo tanto que me salgan cuatro caras
es 0.5 por 0.5 por 0.5 por 0.5 es decir
cara y cara y cara y cara y por lo tanto
la probabilidad de esta rama es decir de
que me salga una moneda que sea normal y
además que usaran cuatro caras seguidas
pues va a ser un cuarto que da la
probabilidad de que me saliera cara por
la probabilidad de que me usaran cuatro
caras seguidas en esta ocasión que es
0.5 elevado a la cuarta así que vamos a
hacerlo con la calculado
cuanto me sale así que llamemos a la
calculadora vamos a aprenderla borramos
todo esto y ahora si tres cuartos que
multiplica y ojo este x no es un x del
denominador es una multiplicación de
toda la fracción entonces me queda tres
cuartos que multiplica a 0.55 elevado a
la cuarta puntos 55 elevado a la cuarta
y esto me sale este número te enorme
entonces para no escribirlo lo voy a
poner aquí no no no ya se voy a hacer
primero todas las operaciones entonces
entonces esto es lo que obtengo al
multiplicar por lo de arriba ahora me
voy a fijar en lo de abajo y un cuarto
que multiplicaba apuntó 5 elevado a la
cuarta y esto es 0.0 15 625 por lo tanto
aquí lo voy a poner y fíjense bien la
probabilidad total de la primera rama
era todo esto de aquí que me sale del
resultado esta cosa horrible que tengo
acá arriba mientras que por otro lado la
probabilidad de que yo tenga la segunda
rama es decir de que tengo una moneda
normal y además
en cuatro caras va a ser este resultado
de aquí abajo y bueno si yo lo que
quiero es la probabilidad total de
obtener en mis cuatro lanzamientos
cuatro caras pues lo que hay que hacer
es sumar estas dos cantidades por lo
tanto antes de escribirlo complicarme la
vida en poniendo todos estos numeritos
vamos a sumar las recuerden que lo que
queremos es la probabilidad de que pase
una o la otra yo tengo es punto f 0.015
625 ya esto le voy a sumar punto 0 6 8 6
8 6 29
29 6 8 7 5 6 8 7 5
la suma de todo esto y que es 0.0 84 25
entonces esa sí la voy a apuntar
entonces de la primera rama la
probabilidad me salio 0.06 8 629 y lo
voy a redondear a 7 al final y abajo me
salio la probabilidad de 0.0 15 625 esto
es cierto y ahora si cuando yo sumo
estas 2 y bueno lo podemos hacer sumando
número por número pero yo lo que hice
fue agarrar la calculadora y realizar
esta suma entonces la suma de la
probabilidad de la primera rama más la
probabilidad de la segunda rama me había
salido 0.08 425 ya redondeado y ahora si
esta es la probabilidad de que me salgan
cuatro caras y si yo lo quiero ver en
porcentaje lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicarlo por 100 y me queda 8.425
por ciento y si lo quiero redondear un
poco me queda 8.43 por ciento
y bueno también cabe aclarar que está
probabilidad es un poco mayor a la
probabilidad de obtener cuatro caras si
tuviéramos solamente cuatro monedas
normales la probabilidad es un poco
mayor porque si te das cuenta las
monedas que tienen un truco tiene una
probabilidad mayor de que me salga cara
lo que hace que esta probabilidad total
aumentó un poco y espero que este
problema te haya ayudado a entender un
poco más la probabilidad de pendiente